and I'm joined Now by Ice Cube or Ice
Cube thank you so much for joining me
thanks for having me great to have you
it's good to be here Bonafide a legend
oh thank you thank you let me call a
legend uh
that's cool you know uh it's it's cool
it's it's interesting because I'm still
you know here and I'm I still feel like
I got so much to do so
um it's nice you were born O'Shea
Jackson who actually calls you O'Shea uh
my mom my my pops my my wife
um
my brothers and sisters sometimes but
mostly everybody call me cute is is
O'Shea different to cube yeah yeah yeah
and what shade's my real
my real name and and when I hear that
I'm either looking for my family or a
check you know I mean like you're gonna
call me or say hope you got a check and
um cube is what my friends been calling
me since I was 12 years old
this
a lot of stuff about the state of the
world about the state of America
where do you see things right now
I think um
I think you know
people are very polarized in all kind of
ways people are
afraid to speak out
because of the cancer culture Council I
said cancer cancel culture that we have
today so I just think you know people
are
afraid and they're running to their
Corners you know in a way it is a cancer
cancer
it behaves like that it does because it
makes not only the person that's getting
canceled
uh they're trying to shut them up but
anybody's watching now they shut up
because they say if it can happen to
this guy it can happen to me so by by
Smashing somebody who says something
that you might not like and canceling
them
it actually reverberates throughout the
whole community and everybody now
is watching what they say all the time
we'll see what's the answer to this
because I think it's crazy in a
democracy like the United States like
United Kingdom the people are too
frightened to speak their mind to say
what they think what do we do about this
I think you say what you want to say
and to hell with the consequences you
got to be willing to fight for your
rights and fight for what you believe in
and if you're a person who believes in
freedom of speech you have to fight
and say what you feel and let chips fall
where they may and uh stand on that and
you know it may not be an easy road but
um I think you feel better about
yourself when you say what needs to be
said at the time it needs to be said and
not afterwards where you go home and
think I should have said this
when that guy was there or when I was
there I should have said that and I
didn't that haunts you more you can
definitely say what the hell you like on
this show it's cool it's called
uncensored well that's why I'm here man
you know that even we've been on citizen
um let me ask you this
is America
more racist or less racist than when you
were a kid
I think it's pretty much the same
because it's uh it's institutionalized
and
you know the institution takes on
different
faces so to speak uh but
you know I don't know if the if racism
in the financial sector or has gotten
any better
um
we still
have a hard time getting Capital when we
need it we still have a hard time
um having that access to to those you
know currency streams that's out there
um and and so it affects us in the same
way in 1865
black people on
um
maybe one or two percent of America
and I believe we're still in that same
place is that right yeah it's barely
changed barely has changed it's in some
ways it's gotten worser I mean worser
but it's gotten worse
um
I think the corner commission did
something in
1968 about the poverty
um
in America and how it affects all the
people and and we're we're worse than we
were in 1968.
the Lost
rapper that I interviewed in this very
Studio was yay Kanye West yeah
you've had a wobbly relationship with
him but you're back you're back on track
I read that you you saw him in fact a
few days ago yeah a couple weeks ago uh
I mean we were always cool you know he
just he spoke my name without really
explaining what he meant and I and I
just really couldn't leave that
statement out there without you know he
never explained what he meant and so I
had to you know kind of rebut that but
since then we've talked and and I think
I think yay understands that
generalizing
will will always get you in
in more hot water than being very
specific
you know because I haven't really seen
much of it since I interviewed him he's
kind of disappeared I mean how is he
how's he dealing with what's happened to
him
um I believe he's doing great you know
he's still
you know dealing with um
with some people trying to hold on to
his money
um but for the most part I believe he's
um in a good space I think he's
you know learned a lot from this past
year and you know hopefully he'll come
out better on the other side when you
saw some of the crazier things he was
saying the anti-semitic statements he
was making what did you feel as someone
who knew him well what did you feel
about that
I felt that um if he was really
upset with specific people that
that the the message he was saying would
uh would kind of hijack what he's really
um
upset about you know and um
and you know that's that's kind of what
happened
um you just can't generalize you have to
be specific
especially if you're
um talking about
uh anybody any race of people you have
to be specific on who exactly you're
talking about
let's talk about the music industry huge
amount of attention been given to
artificial intelligence now yeah clearly
has awesome power not least to replicate
how people like you would make music
what do you feel about that I think it's
terrible I think it's uh
it's going to make people lazier less
creative
um
you know could you imagine if an actor
like if I decided not to do a sequel
and the movie company said we have
we have the rights to your likeness
right we're gonna put you in this sequel
whether you want to be or not right we
have the right to so now they use AI to
put ice cube in a movie I don't want to
be in saying things I don't want to say
in doing things I wouldn't do so to me
that's terrible or or taking an artist
that's passed away and having them do a
new song
with lyrics that they may not agree with
um it's just you know we're just it's a
slippery slope that it will hurt us more
than it will help us is there a benefit
that you can see well you could use AI
to enhance what you do
um
I mean we use you know automation here
and there to
help advance and make our sound better
but you know once you take the
paintbrush out of the painter's hand
is it really
a painting from him you know right well
it's an interesting question isn't it is
it I mean I don't know like if I if
somebody does a ice cube AI song
how could it be an Ice Cube song it's
it's an artificial it's like a mannequin
or a puppet or you know that's how I
look at it it's not real do you think
it's going to kill us all artificial
intelligence
um
I interviewed Professor Stephen Hawking
before he died and I said what's the
biggest threat to mankind he said when
artificial intelligence learns to
self-design that's it yeah I think
you know there are it's already figuring
us out in a lot of different ways
um I've heard that it's learned how to
lie yeah
um
you know this is this is the
you know in every science science
fiction movie this is the beginning of
the end yes yeah definitely if you knew
it was about to win what would you what
would you do on your last day
um you've got 24 hours to live hug my
family love them explain to them how
much I care about them
um
you know pray to my maker
um and prepare myself
to meet him
would you ever lost meal
probably so what would you have
everything I could stuff
he died right yeah yeah yeah you know
I'll be probably sick off everything on
that day you turned down a nine million
dollar movie role in 2021 because you
wouldn't take the covid vaccine it's
being mandated in Hollywood at the time
and he regrets a lot of money not at all
and I want regret you know my thought
when I heard that story you must be even
richer than I think you are
I mean everybody can use nine million
dollars I don't care how rich they think
they are you know everybody can use that
money I could have used that money my
family could use that money but I felt
like you know your health
is worth more than all the money in the
world because if you had all the money
in the world and you wasn't healthy
you would you would use that money to
get healthy so
um to me it was an experimental drug
and um they had no time to really see
the long-term effects like most I'm
vaccinated I've been vaccinated when I
was a kid but these are drugs that have
been tested for decades and you know
pretty much most of the side effects I
mean ultimately I felt about covert
vaccines that once it was established
against what they initially thought that
you could still transmit the virus
whether you were vaccinated or not to me
it becomes a personal choice then it's
down to you yeah without a doubt and you
know the pharmaceutical companies made a
lot of money
um
businesses close you know it was a it's
like an incentive
even when things are not going right to
keep going
um it's kind of like the war machine you
know if you make the bullets and the
Band-Aids you're gonna always want to be
in war because it's profitable if you
watch out are you going to vote for next
year no it's what we would call in
Britain the Hobson's choice
hell what's that mean it means it
doesn't matter your matter which way you
go you're going to get screwed I mean
Joe Biden looks like he barely knows
what day it is Donald Trump might be in
a prison cell so if that's the choice
what does it say about America
um
that you know America needs to
re-examine
where we are where we're going
who we want to lead us
and what kind of country we actually
want to be you know um
a lot of choices
you know I've become independent
and all this because I like to sit back
and see you know who's really gonna be
the best choice
um unfortunately the choices are not
um
always Top Notch so have you thought of
running yourself oh I would never run it
might be a vacancy now can you no
exceeded
no I don't want to be a politician you
know they can King me like me well
actually I've always felt if it hadn't
been for King George III being so
useless you could still have the Monica
here and it could be king peers I mean
right I can share the phone with you
yeah King peers and King Cube
hey uh I think it's only room for one
king now I'm saying are you telling me
to move
all right I'll see I'll see maniacal
power to kingcube okay thank you I
appreciate it great to see you thank you
good to see you always